m
in
muhamed Salli
We Begin by praising Allah subhah wa
taala with praises and exaltations that
only he is worthy of We Begin by sending
his salaat and his Salat His blessings
and his peace upon the last and final
messenger Muhammad abdah
then we begin this final reminder of the
evening and I begin it firstly and
foremostly by thanking my brothers here
in London this is my third or fourth or
maybe even fifth visit to the city and
speaking
alhamd to our brothers
those that have been giving da in this
country alhamdulillah and we've known
them for over two decades
alhamdulillah and we've been United with
them over the last two decades
alhamdulillah as to the growth of the da
in the city of Da in the city and in the
country we ask Allah waala to reward
those who have put in the work reward
those who continue to call the people to
this path
no this path this path
of it is the path that
Allah has mentioned in the Quran
when he exited our
father and we mention this Ayah
from
when he said
to said
when he exited Our Father
Adam from J he said to
[Music]
him when there comes to you guidance
from
me the one who follows my guidance
then there is no fear upon them and they
have no worries there's no fear of what
they will see in the future in the nor
should they have anxiety of what they
left behind them this is the promise of
Allah for the one who follows the
guidance of
Allah so the
ofal was established and it was set to
our father
it was said to our father
Adam and for those that will come after
him from his loins that you have nothing
to worry nothing to fear As Long as You
Follow
guidance As Long as You Follow The
Guidance that I send by way of the
prophets and Messengers by way of the
books you follow
that there's no fear nothing to worry
about just follow the guidance and it is
this guidance that
Allah mentions in the Quran when he
says indeed the religion with Allah is
Islam and Allah who subhah he
says the one who wants a religion other
than Islam in this there's two meanings
the one who wants a religion other than
Islam he doesn't want Islam he wants
Christianity Buddhism sism whatever it
is it's not going to be accepted from
him he will be in the Hereafter from the
losers but also those who want those who
want actions that are in contradiction
to the Quran and the Sunnah they are
from the Innovations in the religion if
they are not from Islam as our
mother narrates in the of IM alkari and
theah of IM Muslim that the messeng of
allaham he
said the one who innovates in this
religion of ours what is not from it
then it is rejected so the meaning of
this
Ayah if you do an action outside of the
guidance of Allah
tala outside of the revelation of Allah
waala Allah T didn't reveal anything
about this act of worship or about this
man or this a this is newly developed
newly invented and it has no
relationship to Quran
and if you do this then Allah tal will
reject it why
the religion with Allah is Islam and
Islam is what
Allah what he has sent down as
Revelation be it in the Quran or be it
in the Sunnah of the Prophet Muhammad
s we mention four points
tonight bringing our lecture series for
the evening to an end and these are four
points that Al
from the students
of May Show both of the
mercy and he has a poem that he
wrote at the request of his teacher a
abdah in Theo of the religion
[Music]
it
is the means of
reaching how do you
reach in understanding the of the
religion meaning the foundational
principles of the religion which consist
of
what the
of and the following of the messenger
hence this book is an explanation of the
sh then he explained the book he
explained the poem then and what is the
name of what is the name of the
explanation of this poem does anyone
know say it out loud if you know
it it's printed in three volumes and
towards the end of this treaties
he mentions four Affairs regarding the
Sunnah and we know that the Sunnah is
Islam and Islam is the
Sunnah the Sunnah is Islam and Islam is
the Sunnah there's no separating between
the two
so he mentions four
Affairs and the first of those Affairs
is the statement of Allah
on this day I have perfected for you the
religion I've completed the religion for
you and I have completed my favor upon
you Allah
in this Ayah refers to
Islam for a moment I want my brothers
and my sisters to not think about Islam
but I want you to think about your
Islam your state of being a Muslim
forget about everyone else for a
moment your state of being a Muslim you
are a Muslim Allah tala did not choose
Abu Talib
Allah did not choose
Abu and they were related to The Prophet
Muhammad sah alaihi wasallam and over
Abu Talib and ab Allah chose
you over the uncle of the Prophet where
the messenger of
allaham Sat by his side
say
say a word that I can use with Allah
and abuali didn't say it but you said it
Allah guided you to it Allah chose you
for it what does Allah say about that
Islam he
says I have completed my favor my
blessing for you from the greatest of
the blessings
of is that Allah completed this religion
and he guided us to it
he completed the religion and he guided
us to it and Allah refers to guidance in
the Quran as a remember when the M of s
wasam when he gave da to his
uncle Abu Talib and Abu Jal was there
and he told him to
say and Abu
said are you going to leave the religion
of ABD mutb so the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said it again my uncle
say
say I need these words so I can stand in
front of Allah with something
say Abu
J are you going to leave the religion of
your father and the last words of ab
were his last words were I am on the
religion of abdb and he died the
religion that he did not accept and you
accepted Allah labels it as a
they come to you claiming to have done
you a favor some of the bad who accepted
Islam without War the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam the sahaba did not need
to fight
them and they accepted Islam
when it came for zaka and the zaka came
they came to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam claiming that we've done
a favor look you didn't have to fight us
we deserve zaka we deserve some
money we've done you a favor Allah
revealed the
Ayah they come to you as though they've
done you a favor by accepting Islam say
to them do not portray your acceptance
of of Islam as a
favor Allah did you a
favor that he guided you to Islam why
because Allah tal everything Allah does
has hikma wisdom so why is it Allah tal
did not choose Abu Tali why is it Allah
tal did not choose Abu why is it that
Allah tal did not the father of ibraim
or the son of no or the husband of AIA
why or the wife of L
why because you have S Allah he guides
those whose Hearts have have
truthfulness if Allah knows in someone's
heart there is good Allah will guide
them may Allah inas the good in our
hearts so Allah he completed the
religion Islam was a and the completion
of Islam was a greater than the
first the Jews they would come
to they would say to
they said there is a verse in your
book if it was revealed upon us the Jews
we would have taken that day as a day of
Celebration
so he
said which
verse and he
said on this day I have perfected for
you the religion so the yahood the Jews
they saw the completion of Islam
the completion of the religion to be
a so this is the
first Allah he perfected the religion
for
us everything that we need is sh is
included in the religion look at the
life of the Prophet
sallam the M ofam did not live hidden
from the
people he did not live hidden from the
people there's a Hadith of the M
of said better who's better from amongst
you those that mix with the
people they mix with the people and
they're patient upon their
harm they're
better they're better than who the ones
that don't mix with the people they're
Hermits they s in their house they don't
speak to anyone they don't talk to
anyone they stay away from every
everyone because they don't want to be
harmed by anyone our
messenger was an example of this he was
an example of this it is said regarding
the M he would walk the streets of
Medina and a slave girl a young slave
girl will come and take his hand and
take him to any corner of Madina she
wanted this is what the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam was like our
proph
Muhammad would ride upon a mule and he
would have the young sitting behind him
teaching them the
religion the
mam would sit with the sah a sah would
bring her child and put him in the lap
of the prophet and he would urinate on
the lap of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam Allah abbar what an example you
have in Muhammad sallai wasam what an
example you have
call
announcement call announcement follow
calls pleas remove immediately the first
call LB 51x lb 51x the second call LG 57
vrj LG 57 vrj the third call s y 63 c s
z and the final call LS
23 b o p please
call so the first Affair regarding Al
Islam regarding the
Sunnah is what that Allah tal completed
it Allah tala gave you
a a path which is
must from the characteristics of a
is that
it's it's meaning what it's wide it's
expensive so everything is explained in
it the of
said I've left nothing that will bring
you closer to Allah except that I've
commanded you with
it I've left nothing that will bring you
further away away from Allah except that
I prohibited you from it it comes in a
Hadith the messenger of Allah s.
wasallam
said the sahab they were traveling with
the messeng of Allah sallallah alaihi
wasallam and the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam he said to them
them there was no Prophet before
[Music]
me except that it was an obligation upon
him it was an obligation that he had to
tell his
um of the good that he
knew mean meaning it was not allowed for
the prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam or
the and the r that came before him that
W would come down revelation will come
down and they would hide it and put it
away this is not
allowed it was not allowed you know
amongst
us the M ofam he said
you see something wrong change it with
your hand you can't with your tongue you
can't then dislike it in your heart that
is the weakest level of Iman so there
may Bean in our families there may be
amongst our brothers they must be there
may be amongst our communities certain
Affairs that we see then they're from
theat it is something we dislike but a
person may remain silent upon it either
because they don't have the authority or
they don't know how to speak about it
they may remain silent or they know the
weakness of an individual so they may
remain silent the messeng of s alaihi
wasallam if something wrong was done in
front of him he was not allowed to
remain
silent because if he remained silent
that would become a sun
the sahabah were
watching they would see how he would act
and react with the people coming
in and from the Sunnah we know is
what it was done in front of the
prophet he didn't say
anything it becomes a
Sunnah so the M of s how many ath do we
find where the Prophet sallallahu alhi
wasallam something is done in front of
him
and he's not quiet rather there's
Affairs that are said
theam goes out to find the people who
said
it the three men or four men who came to
the house of the Prophet Alat asking
about his I in the house they knew him
outside so they
asked the mothers of the Believers how
is he in the house what does he do in
the house so when they were informed
they belittle their own work worship one
of them said I'm going to pray all night
not sleep another said I'm going to fast
not break my fast another one said I'm
not going to marry women a fourth one in
another narration said I will never eat
meat when the news reaches the messeng
of s alaihi wasall he goes out looking
for them are you the ones who said such
a such
thing did you say these
Affairs and then he repli commends them
I fear Allah more than
you but I pray and I sleep I fast and I
break my f and I marry
women so the messenger of Allah s Alam
when this
came he gave it to the
umah this is the second point of the
Sunnah this is important because someone
may say that everything came and it was
in the box but not everything came out
of the
box there was nothing
from except that the messenger of Allah
s. wasam taught it to someone in the
um the very famous Hadith of who
wasif who was who sat with the prophet
wasallam on the on the dun
he
said do you know the right of Allah upon
the servants the right of the servants
upon Allah
said and the know
best and he told them the right of Allah
don't worship anyone but Allah the right
of the servant Allah does not punish the
one who does not commit sh
he
says Glad
Tidings let me tell the
people don't don't tell
them they will become dependent upon
it the Shah from theith is what this was
from Allah upon Muhammad Sall alaihi
wasallam he feared some of the people
would become dependent upon it even then
he did not hide
it he didn't keep
it he told mu
ja mu jaal only spoke the
Hadith when he was about to die and he
feared he would die hiding knowledge
with him that's when he narrated The
this is the second Affair the
first Allah T completed for you the
religion Allah completed for you the
religion everything in this
religion everything you need is found in
this
religion number two he sent to you a
prophet Sall alai wasam who did not keep
anything from you
he did not keep anything from you how
many aith do you find the
m is in his house but there is a sah
there's a sahabi with
himd and the messenger
ofam was married to the to the aunt of
Abdullah Abbas so when it was a night of
his abdah Abbas would spend the night
with the m of s Al wasallam sleep on the
bed some of the scholars they say the
and the aunt who was the aunt of abdah
and she was
also
from she was the aunt her sister was
married to
AB so when it would be the night of
Abbas abdah Abbas would stay with the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
sleep on the bed at the feet of the
messeng of Allah
and so he narrates what he saw
and he narrates everything he sees from
the M of Allah s alaihi wasallam he
narrates that
Abu used to be with the m of Allah so
much that when he would disappear the M
of wasallam would say Abu where did you
go this is how the M was didn't hide
anything the third
Affair if truly Islam and the
Sunnah are as we have just described it
they are complete
and they have been fully
propagated fully taught nothing
[Music]
hidden then the next Affair regarding
the Sunnah and
Islam is the Commandment of
Allah is the Commandment of Allah
enter into Islam
completely enter into Islam
completely do not follow the footsteps
ofan indeed he is for you a plain or a
clear
enemy so we have been
commanded to enter into Islam completely
and Allah's messenger and Allah
says what the M of Allah commands you
with take
it and if he prohibits you from
something then leave it
this is a command my brothers sisters to
accept Islam in its
entirety all of it
together because the opposite of that is
what that you pick and choose I'll
accept this I won't accept this this one
agrees with me that one doesn't agree
with me you find amongst the
people are those that have been deceived
into this
that their their M or their their the
ruler that they have of acceptance and
rejection is
notan and
and
but whatever the agrees
with whatever the agrees with they'll
accept it but if it doesn't then they're
going to go searching in the books right
oh look I found this Alim this Alim said
this oh Subhan Allah I found this mhab
this mhab says I don't need to do this
I'm not going to do this oh Subhan Allah
I found this was the opinion of this
that's this one and now I have a I have
a I don't need to do this anymore
because said in such and such book that
this isn't the meaning even though the
statement goes against the even though
the Hadith are clear even though the
majority say what they say even though
the affair has been clear with for 1,400
years but I found an that said this I
don't need to do
this then who what is your ruler how do
you accept and
reject
muhm he makes a point regarding
the those that accept and reject the
names and attributes of
Allah so he says their ruler is is what
their whatever their is willing to
accept even though each one of us in
this room is different in our
intelligence many of you are more
intelligent than me many of you
understand more than I
understand so if Allah tal was to make
the the measuring stake of acceptance
and rejection then there would be no
Unity among the umah
none but you find amongst them what you
will say that Allah subhah waala he says
in the
Quran and he is the all hearing and he's
the all knowing and you go to them and
say do you say that Allah can hear they
say yes I say Allah can hear do you say
that Allah has knowledge they say yes
Allah has knowledge yes I don't deny
that you say why why do you accept this
they'll say Allah mentions it in the
Quran
that Allah he is the all hearing he's
the allseeing I accepted it's in the
Quran we say the same Quran
says that your Lord will come and the
angels will
come do you believe that Allah will come
they say l i don't believe Allah will
come why it's in the
Quran it's in the Quran Allah
says Allah will come and they say no
it's not be fitting it's not befitting
for Allah to come who are you to say
what is befitting and not befitting
Allah says Allah will come and you say
that it's not be fitting for Allah to
come yeah Subhan
Allah so what is your measuring
stick this my brothers and sisters is
the way
of those that came before
us and
Allah he says regarding
them do you believe in some of the book
and then you disbelieve in other
portions of the
book this aah was revealed because the
because of B is in the Arabian pen
when the pagans would fight
Wars they would what they would take
sides and they would end up killing each
other they would end up killing each
other even though Allah subhana took a
covenant from
them and we took the cover from you
don't spill your own
blood don't push your own cells meaning
people from your own any bani is don't
push your own people out of their
homes but because they would take sides
they would end up killing each
other but Allah tal mentions
if those same ones that they killed
those same
ones that they exited from their homes
if they came to them
as as prisoners of War they would be
willing to Ransom them because that was
from
their so Allah he said to
them so you will you're ready to Ransom
them because your allows it but that
same Shar told you you can't kill them
to begin
with so Allah reprimanded
them are you going to take some of the
book and then you're going to leave some
of the
book what is the
compensation how should that person be
compensated the one who does this except
loss in this world
so this affair is from the Affairs or
from the actions of bani
is and we have been prohibited from this
and Allah
says every time a messenger came to you
with something you did not
desire you would fill up with pride
a portion of them the prophets and
Messengers you be lied you said you're
lying Allah didn't send
anything and some of them you killed
off when Allah T mentions these stories
in the Quran of the people that came
before us my brothers and sisters It's
Not For Your
Entertainment It's Not For Your
Entertainment it's not story
time it's because Allah tal wants you to
take a lesson from what they
did from the greatest of the blessings
of Allah tal on this um is that Allah
has
narrated the mistakes of past nations in
our
book
why why because we can take lesson from
it we can take lesson from
it so our Command or the third Affair
that we mentioned after number one the
completion of the
religion number two the propagation of
the religion
completely now number three the command
to enter into Islam
completely enter into Islam
completely the fourth Affair and the
final
Affair is that the
Quran the Sunnah and
Islam become the measuring stick of
acceptance and
rejection and
Allah he
says it is not for the believing man nor
the believing woman
that when Allah and his messenger have
ruled in an affair they've passed
judgment in an affair that they should
have a choice in that
Affair this is from the obligations of
Iman from the obligations of Iman is
that when
Allah or the messenger of Allah
s they pass judgment in an affair the
choice voice is no longer
there the only words we can say
is we have heard and we have obeyed that
is it there's no other choice when he
said you disagree about something then
return it back to Allah and his
messenger only if you believe in Allah
and the last meaning from the dictates
of your IM in Allah in the last day is
what this is demanded from your
IM demand it from your
Iman these are the four affairs
that are
mentioned along with the prohibition of
and innovation in the religion which
fits into the fourth point that we
mentioned and we suffice inshallah in
conclusion with the speech of aikh
Muhammad Aman
aljami and this is M
this is is
famous even
amongst
because some time ago we would be
referred to as what Al
J we are Al
J and we are the followers of Muhammad
ji and prior to that it was alah
these are wahhabis these were the
followers of Muhammad ABD wahhab which
was a because Abdul wahab was the father
of
Islam who was a father today they have a
new
name tomorrow they'll have another
name and the next day they'll have
another name and they'll continue to
come up
because it is from their disease
that they want to ascribe their own
disease to other than
themselves and
asmed he said that really the proper
name for us if you were to give a name
of a man would be
muhammadi because for us we have one
IM and that is Muhammad Al Mustafa s
wasam whose
shahada to whose
messengership we bear witness that is
our
Im so
Muhammad he
says from the mistakes that are
widespread amongst the ranks of the
Muslims today
that every Jama every group from amongst
the
Muslims rather even every individual
from those
groups at times
you that he only wants to take from
Islam
those aspects that he likes that are
befitting to
him but he'll leave off the other
aspects of
Islam he'll leave off the other aspects
of Islam right this is not a
praiseworthy action someone comes and
says right that each of these Jama each
of these they have taken just one hold
of one thing from Islam so so has taken
one thing and the has taken one thing
and this has taken this and that has
taken
that we don't want this we don't want
all of these taking a j of Islam and
leaving everything off and say oh if you
want to see the entirety of Islam look
at all of them together like they're
pieces of a
puzzle the obligation on us
individually as a group as
an we have to take Islam all of it
individually he
says and they leave off the other
aspects of
Islam so they see oh it's sufficient for
me
I take by this one thing I don't need to
take by anything
else right I pray my this is suffices
me suffices me I don't need to do
anything else I don't need to follow any
of the other Commandments I don't need
to stay away from any of the
prohibitions I pray five times a day or
some of them will say alhamdulillah I
pray J every Friday every Friday jum IM
is renewed and I'll see you next
week or
Ramadan every year alhamdulillah 11
months I do what I want to do on in
Ramadan I'll pray five times a
day read the
Quan this is sufficient and these are
exaggerated
points these are exaggerated points that
I'm
mentioning most are not guilty of these
exaggerated points inshallah we ask
Allah to guide our
hearts most are not and Allah knows best
but what we are guilty of is when
something comes to us that we don't like
we go we used to refer to it a decade
two decades ago as fwa shopping right
who can I find that says I don't have to
do
this and this is the of
the the blind follower this is the of
the blind follower as for
the As for the S
the the sun all of these
names they mean
what what do they mean they mean that
you have to follow
something you have to follow the Sal you
have to follow the Sunnah you have to
follow
the so when something is unclear Al IM
Malik
he states that some students of his came
to him and said that if we find there is
a difference of opinion amongst the
scholars do we say that both of the
opinions are correct M mik said no
rather one is correct and one is
incorrect find the one that is correct
that is the way of the salafi the Sunni
the
that is the
way that we return back to Quran and
Sunnah and we figure out what is the
correct
opinion what is the correct opinion here
what is supported by Quran and Sunnah
and Theo of the religion what is
supported here by that and then you
follow
that not that when it comes and there's
an opinion in front of you and you sayas
I like this opinion
better I like this opinion
better so I'm going to follow this one
why makes my life
easy and if someone comes to you and
says why do you do this you
say opinion
of that's what you're going to
say that's what you're going to say
on would you not feel safer standing in
front of Allah saying yeah Allah
the Sunnah came to me from the prophet
of
Allah and this is what I understood and
I followed the Sunnah to the best of my
knowledge we you going to stand on that
day and say I
follow may Allah have mercy upon that IM
muham all of them
hammad these were men of
Sunnah these were men of
Sunnah they didn't care who held what
opinion and who did not hold that
opinion read their books
read their writings they were men of
Sunnah
M will suffice with this
amount when he gave T to a number
of from amongst them
Muhammed from amongst
them a
from amongst them Abu
Muhammed from
among and then he said
what do not blindly follow any one of
them that is
the that is the
that was the of
the they would ask each other if someone
did
something
the what caused you to do
this what proof do you
have so return back to the way of
he says he's from those that took from
the sah says they
were and their path was the safest
path their path was the safest path so
be
from I'm going to suffice with these
words inshallah I'm going to leave with
an advice for myself firstly and
foremostly because my first obligation
on is is me not you my first obligation
is me not you this is an advice for
myself and then for all of you be from
those be from those who visit the salafi
mar of this city and outside of this
city find the durus the classes that are
going
on and ensure that they are a part of
your weekly schedule
every
week they are a part of your weekly
schedule does not matter what your day
was like does not matter how busy it was
does not matter you didn't get time with
your family if you didn't get time with
your family say let's go we're going to
the
lesson do not leave your marak is empty
at times of lessons and
D this is the differentiating factor
between Us and
Them this is what has defined our
Mar in the West on the advice of
the of our Scholars to be from those who
study the
religion
how the question is how would you advise
the Muslims to benefit from healthc Care
Professionals with depression for
depression and issues like this I'll
advise themani I'll advise them that I
am not a professional nor do I have in
this
Bob right so I'm not a professional nor
do I have in this Bob as far as
depression and things like this I will
mention that Dua making Dua
to is from the best of medicines the
recitation of the Quran is from the best
of medicines staying away from what is
Haram is from the best of
medicines making of Allah is from the
best of medicines as for these Affairs
and I advise my brothers to
ask as he is more learned than myself in
this B and it is not appropriate for me
to answer a question that I've not
studied will suffice with this
I ask to give us the opportunity to meet
again inshallah in the near
future if there's anything correct that
I've said that indeed it is from Allah
anything incorrect is from myself I ask
Allah firstly and then all of you to
forgive me for any of my shortcomings